the Greek island of Lesbos has a
three-way conflict on its hands as
Europe's frontline to the migrant crisis
some locals are taking more of a stance
against the swelling numbers of refugees
held up on the island and the NGOs have
been drawn into battle to reduce move of
people but not small a couple of
hundreds they start blocking the streets
they start stopping cars that many NGOs
have bans so they will stop in the bands
or they were stopping the rental cars
and they will just matching them like
beaten them throwing stone at them
taking people out and beating people
between journalists and chasing also
volunteers so there's a big steam
motivation now of people that works in
NGOs this is because they they want to
pass the message that NGOs profit from
human suffering finally we got the
permission to dock in this part in
mytilini we think it's a very good sign
from the authorities that they made it
possible to sign also to say that the
it's not just a group of fascists that
are going to take over the how things
work on this island the migrants remain
in overcrowded facilities with lack of
hygiene frankly living in terrible
conditions in a desperate move to try to
pursue some of them to go back home the
EU is offering 2,000 euros as bait but
some of them have travelled so far so is
that money really enough to make them go
back if I go back to Nigeria they are
going to kill me so to me - tada hero
will not take me back to Nigeria so that
will be an individual opinion
mm URIs is not enough I haven't left my
country for money I love because it
wasn't safe there now I feel protected
the Third Front is the one created by
right-wing groups who do not appreciate
their picture istic island
turning into a giant migrant camp
every day these people pass through our
town without asking anyone they come and
steal from us
people here are fed up that's why we
decided to make these barricades we
gather here as often as we can to
prevent the refugees from entering the
town and force them to take another
route
we have never been aggressive towards
them and we have never clashed with them
on the contrary they come in gangs and
try to argue with us
our main goal is to protect our village
the shops and banks sign me to Lenny why
do they want to pass through here and
since the coronavirus has been confirmed
in mid to Lenny it's another reason to
prevent them from entering here this
additional struggle has seen locals pay
a very big price tourist season has
become something of the past and
businesses have even been forced to pull
down shutters for good
our life here is horrible we were
happier in the past but they robbed us
destroy our properties they even break
into our houses most of the shops are
closed and the refugees are the reason
there are 25 thousand of them and only a
thousand of us
lesbos is the island that has been
suffering the most
the Moria camp is overcrowded with
refugees I believe we all have to sit
down and find a solution because we
can't live like this anymore our town
can't survive like this we are fed up
this island might be a tiny Greek
paradise that the Sun shines all here
around but down here on the ground it's
clouded over fear uncertainty and anger
evangelist ipsus from lesbos grace for
our team
you